Disney movies are some of the most paused
movies out there - usually because eagle-eyed
Easter egg hunters are keen to spot fun intentional
inclusions by Disney's animators, such as
characters from other movies making cameos
in the background.
However, quite often, pausing Disney movies
at just the right time can result in an image
Disney might not be so keen for you to see.
Whether it's a character looking a little
less attractive than they usually do, a situation
being made to look inappropriate when taken
out of context, or otherwise, there are some
Disney movie screenshots that weren't meant
to be seen when paused.
This video will take a look at some entertaining
examples of that.
We hope you enjoy it - and make sure you subscribe
to ScreenRant's YouTube channel to enjoy more
like it in the future!
Here are ten paused Disney moments they don't
want you to know about.
The Little Mermaid
In 1989's The Little Mermaid, the second time
Ariel and Eric meet, it is when Eric discovers
Ariel on a beach, after she'd lost her voice.
The first time they'd met, Ariel saved Eric
from drowning and disappeared just as he regained
conscious.
So, in this second meeting, Eric only vaguely
recognised her.
Ariel's desperate attempts to communicate
with Eric without her voice resulted in some
very exaggerated hand gestures - which Eric
seemed to join in with.
If you pause the movie at just the right time,
they don't look like Disney characters at
all - the pair actually look more like members
of The Sopranos!
The Princess and the Frog
Charlotte La Bouff from 2009's The Princess
and the Frog was a very attractive character
- or at least she was meant to be!
Disney's intentions were obviously for the
Southern belle to be physically beautiful
at all times - but a paused moment from one
particular scene in her movie spoils that
notion somewhat!
It comes in the scene when Charlotte puts
Tiana's tiara on her head in the bedroom.
As Charlotte adjusts her top, her face - for
a mere moment - looks absolutely ghastly and
almost pig-like!
Yikes!
Toy Story 2
1999's Toy Story 2 saw the introduction of
some new talking toys that weren't in the
first movie - one of them being the excitable
Jessie.
Buzz Lightyear immediately found himself attracted
to the cowgirl and introduced himself to her
in bumbling fashion.
Jessie seemed impressed and immediately grabbed
Buzz to tell him how sweet she thought he
was.
But if you pause that scene at a very specific
moment, it looks as though she's drunk as
hell, with Buzz looking on concerned and unimpressed
at her unladylike behaviour!
The Fox and the Hound
1981's The Fox and the Hound follows the exploits
of the titular young red fox - Tod - as he
grows into adulthood and tries to make a life
for himself in the forest.
At one point, he encounters the female fox
Vixey for the first time and, soon after meeting
her - which was initially disastrous after
he failed to catch a fish to impress her - she
begins to show him affection, which includes
rubbing herself against him.
Feeling the physical affection of a female
for the first time seems to be too much for
Tod and, if you pause the movie at just the
right moment, it looks as though he's reached
a point of pleasure unsuitable for young viewers!
Hercules
Hercules is, of course, one of the most macho
characters in fiction - that's kind of his
schtick, after all.
In his titular 1997 movie, he meets Meg after
saving her from the giant centaur known as
Nessus, by defeating the beast with his phenomenal
strength - but a few moments later he doesn't
look so macho.
When he goes to see how Meg is, as she's cleaning
her hair in some nearby water, he takes a
hit to the face from her soaking locks when
she turns around.
Pause the scene at the right moment, and you'll
see Herc looking more like the sassiest diva
in town than a super-strong heroic warrior.
Cinderella
1950's Cinderella is one of the sweetest,
most innocent and quintessentially Disney
movies that the company has ever produced.
Nobody could ever take any scenes out of context
from such a family-friendly Disney classic,
right?
Wrong!
In the scene in which the Grand Duke and the
palace footman are peering over the balcony,
pausing it at a certain point looks as though
the pair are indulging in some male-on-male
intimacy that is very unsuitable for children's
eyes!
With the Duke positioned behind, he certainly
appears to be enjoying it.
The footman, however... not so much!
Aladdin
There are a lot of scenes in 1992's Aladdin
in which the titular character is in motion
and, when paused, performing some anatomically
impossible poses - but this one takes the
cake!
The thief and street urchin-turned-hero is
having one of his typical altercations with
the palace guards when one of the guards loses
his pants - it's the scene in which he uses
a fish as a makeshift pair of pants.
Aladdin stretches whilst running and the shape
of his body basically looks like he's broken
every bone he's got!
Seriously, nobody can make their body stretch
and twist like that!
The Emperor's New Groove
The Emperor's New Groove was a 2000 movie
about the titular 18-year-old, selfish, spoiled
and sarcastic titular Emperor Kuzco.
The whole movie's plot is based around him
learning to become a better person after being
turned into a llama - and it's that scene
we're referring to here.
As Kuzco's transformation takes place while
he's sat at a table with Yzma and Kronk, if
you pause the movie at a certain point, mid-transformation,
you'll find that he looks like some animated
characters from a completely different (and
far more adult) franchise - a certain Beavis
and Butt-Head!
Beauty and the Beast
There may be a fantastic live action remake
of Beauty and the Beast coming out this year,
but nobody can forget the wonderful 1991 animated
version of the classic tale.
As with all interpretations of the story,
it featured the vain hunter Gaston and his
loyal, yet often-abused sidekick, LeFou.
There's a scene in which LeFou serenades Gaston
with a song about how great he is - and it
includes a moment in which LeFou wraps a man's
belt around Gaston's neck to demonstrate how
thick and muscular it is.
Unfortunately, when paused, there's a moment
in which Gaston looks as though he's experimenting
with a little BDSM!
Frozen
When Anna and Hans first meet in 2013's Frozen,
Hans and his horse inadvertently knock Anna
into a boat.
Their subsequent interactions are extremely
awkward - both physically and verbally - and
this results in a scene that looks a little...
non-PG, let's say... when it's paused.
Anna falls on top of Hans and, if you pause
it at just the right ... or wrong... frame,
depending on how you look at it, it looks
like Anna is lost in a moment of physical
ecstasy, while Hans looks as though he's embarrassed
that his participation in the encounter has
just come to a premature end.
Thanks for watching our video about ten paused
Disney moments they don't want you to know
about.
Can you think of any other moments from movies
that Disney wouldn't want you to pause?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.